centrale nucléaire américaine la bulle
semble serait abordée mais le danger
n'est pas encore écartée et narre m
beguinot caire un accueil volontairement
tu as fait froid invité du journal
simone veil
elle conduira la liste udf aux élections
européennes
messieurs bonsoir pour commencer ce
journal une grande première une première
médicale
nous savons très bien qu'il nous faut
toujours veiller à ne pas susciter trop
d'espoirs 20 chez les grands malades
c'est pourquoi nous sélectionnons
toujours avec attention ce genre de
performances qui font avancer la science
de plusieurs années mais cette fois je
suis sûr que la faire vous passionnera
une équipe de rueil malmaison pas de
paris a réussi samedi à l'aide d'un
laser de fabrication française à mettre
fin à l'obstruction de les otages d'un
malade de 64 ans le malade souffrait
beaucoup il ne pouvait pas manger des
aliments solides depuis trois mois et il
avait d'ailleurs perdu quelques 25 kg
vous voyez d'ailleurs voir avec
difficulté avant son opération
une aberration si la suisse sans avoir
été endormi oui vous pouvez m'expliquer
un peu et bien voilà explorez le le
gouffre bouche et la fage essayé avec un
rayon laser de percer en droit il faut
prendre lui re son fronton ou de façon à
introduire après une prothèse
on voit parfaitement ses cordes vocales
j'essaie de passe ça va monsieur tout se
fera sans chirurgie uniquement par la
bouche à l'aide d'un endoscope qui
permet à la fois de repérer
l'obstruction de les of ages puis de
forêt le passage dans une autre salle
en plusieurs flash ultra rapide le laser
va pulvériser les cellules qui bouche
les otages
on ne sait pas centrer
c'est un peu mais c'est quand on ressort
en bloc ces six si j'y suis c'est gagné
pis des vaches
on va vérifier la position
c'est la première fois que l'on tente
cette partie là de l'intervention
commence alors le difficile mais déjà un
peu plus connus travail d'élargissement
que l'on sait faire sur d'autres malades
dont les of ages est rétréci mais pas
boucher on va faire passer des olives
métallique de calibre de plus en plus
gros pour atteindre la taille presque
normal d'année chauffage voilà
dirait monsieur quelques flocons de
cendres et les fumées
oui rendez vos doigts monsieur s'agit
bon ne bougeait pas la table voilà on va
pouvoir enfin installer la prothèse
digestives
pas la mouche
bon ouvrez la bouche prend
nombreuses inconnues
bon voilà
moi je suis en position c'est
définitivement gagné
le bonobo deux rivaux comme un ciment
mais ça y est vous pouvez manger matin
qu'est ce que vous allez manger à midi
l'appétit deuxième chapitre de
l'actualité ce soir les suites de
l'accident nucléaire de l'aris beau je
vous précise tout de suite que là encore
il s'agit d'un dossier qui nous
passionne et auquel nous consacrera
demain nous consacrerons de ma la
majeure partie de notre journal de 20
heures car je crois que il ne s'agit pas
de se contenter de faux semblants ou de
vraie peur il faut que tous les éléments
du dossier soient portés à la
connaissance de chacun en france comme
ailleurs
alors sur place aujourd'hui à three
miles island jimmy carter a voulu
conjurer leur angoisse un contrôle et
ses compatriotes en se rendant lui même
pendant une bonne demi-heure au coeur du
danger dans la centrale ses proches ont
d'ailleurs abondamment répété qu en 36
minutes qu'il n'avait pas été plus
irradiés que lors d'une banale radio des
poumons mais pour autant sur place à
rien et vermand réglé même si comme on
le dit la bulle a presque disparu
sur la route qui conduit à la centrale
le cortège du président c'est la
première fois qu'un président des états
unis se rend dans une centrale nucléaire
qui à vienne connaître un accident mais
le président carter connaît le nucléaire
beaucoup mieux que n'importe lequel de
ses collègues puisqu'il a lui même vécu
un accident nucléaire en 1952 dans une
centrale canadienne et chokri veut la
situation et reebok plus grave que celle
qui semble régner à touba azal s'est
fait expliquer toute la situation puis
il a gagné un gymnase situé dans le
centre de la ville de midelt tarn la
plus proche des grandes villes pour
expliquer un peu la situation telle
qu'il avait trouvé à la population venue
très peu nombreuses à cause peut-être
des nombreuses défections de ce week-end
beaucoup de gens sont en effet parties
il se félicite de la première décision
d'évacuation du président du gouverneur
de pennsylvanie en disant que finalement
c'était pas une mauvaise chose mais il
pense que le danger quand même beaucoup
moins
alors on dit en effet que la bulle a
disparu oui alors reprenons
le même dessein excusez moi mais une
centre hassan n'évoluent pas comme ça
avec le coeur du réacteur situé dans une
enceinte de béton
la bulle est en hausse ce réacteur alors
je vais vous faire un gros plan sur
cette bulle
c'est ici que sont les barreaux
d'uranium c'est ici qu'arrivent l'eau de
refroidissement qui doit à tout prix
garder ses barreaux froid il faut pas
que la température monte pour quoi que
un de ces barreaux se met à fondre comme
on semble croire que c'est le cas
et la bulle la voici alors je viens il
ya quelques minutes d'avoir un coup de
fil du correspondant du commissariat
tommy sur place aux états unis qui me
dit
cette bulle semble faire cinq mètres
cubes et non pas 50 ou 100 comment
semblez le croire avant alors cela veut
dire deux choses soit que la bulle se
résorbe c'est ce qu'on annonce partout
soit que peut-être on avait mal mesuré
les dimensions de la bulle avant et cela
je vais vous montrer un peu comment ça
se passe à cet endroit dans une centrale
nucléaire de même type
c'est parce qu'on ne mesure pas
directement fait les calculs pour savoir
comment se présente cette bulle alors la
centrale que vous allez voir maintenant
n'est pas du tout une centrale
américaine
c'est la centrale de fessenheim en
alsace qui est bâti sur le même modèle à
peu de choses près ce qu'il a trois
échangeurs différents vous voyez donc
nous sommes au dessus du coeur vous
voyez un peu d'eau qui miroite c'est
l'eau de la piscine qui est situé juste
au dessus du coeur c'est par cet endroit
qu'ont décharge le combustible quand il
est sorti pour par exemple être
renouvelés comme on le fait chaque année
par tiers ou complètement comme on le
fait au bout d'un an de fonctionnement
de la centrale
voyez si vous voyez très bien les
logements où se mettent les barreaux
combustible alors qu'est ce qui va se
passer maintenant si vraiment il ya bull
ici on pourra effectivement peut-être
l'évacuer par là en tous les cas dans
l'enceinte entière de béton le taux
d'hydrogène qui est ce qu'on craint
beaucoup puis à l'hydrogène mélangé à
l'air peut exploser semble stable est
limitée à 2% donc c'est pour cela qu'on
peut dire que la situation est
apparemment entre les mains des
spécialistes actuels et la température a
quelque peu baissé
pas partout il y a deux barreaux encore
à plus de 200 degrés nous dit haut et
c'est bien sûr la fusion de ces bus la
rockeuse qui inquiète beaucoup
je me tourne maintenant vers simone
grêle
on pas en tant que ministre de la santé
non pas en tant que tête de liste d'une
liste de l'udeac nous en parlons tout à
l'heure mais en tant que président du
conseil de l'information sur
l'électronique les airs alors depuis
quelques mois vous présider ce conseil
vous ne cessez demandé au premier
ministre la publication des documents
officiels est-ce que vous menez la santé
vous ne pouvez pas obtenir plus
rapidement la publication de documents
d'information des banques avaient
effectivement nous sommes préoccupés au
sein de ce comité que davantage de
documents soient publiés mais que pour
la plupart de ces documents il n'était
pas dans une forme qui permettait de les
publier utilement et par exemple j'ai
apporté aujourd'hui des documents qui
concerne le travail du service central
de protection contre les rayonnements
ionisants
c'est un document qui existe depuis
longtemps qui est publié par cet
organisme qui est chargée de calculer de
faire le calcul des rayons ionisants
aussi bien d'ailleurs lorsqu'il s'agit
de la radiographie médicale qui est très
importante qu'on me souvenir tout à
l'heure le président carter que quand il
s'agit des rayons ionisants
produit par des centrales nucléaires
c'est donc un document de très grandes
informulée qui n'est pas public pour
l'instant alors ils n'étaient pas
publics jusqu'à maintenant et je vous
avoue je me le prendrais pour le montrer
c'est une petite phrase ça c'est
simplement une petite brochure sur le
service lui même qui informe de ce
qu'elle nous voilà le rapport d'activité
alors c'est le rapport d'activités 76 le
rapport d'activités 77 et le rapport
d'activités 1978 doit être prêt très
rapidement avec il faut toujours un
certain délai pour avoir toute la
documentation sur une année donc c'est
très rapide et si nous n'avons pas eu
plus rapidement la publication c'est
parce que il fallait absolument intégrer
un certain nombre de renseigne de
lancement pour la présentation
parce que jusqu'à maintenant c'était
destiné uniquement à des spécialistes
qui donc la veuve a besoin qu'on leur
explique en quoi certaines on
reconstitue consistait certaines de ces
radiations
là nous avons voulu qu'il soit vraiment
à la portée du public et du grand public
donc le rendre plus lisible remarquer
que cela prend je m'excuse c'est encore
ne sais pas encore enfin c'est encore
difficile à comprendre les calculs
notamment moi je dois dire que ça
dépasse mes compétences marque que vous
avez demandé aux cités par exemple 6 et
des auditions publiques un petit peu
comme aux états unis
non
non ce que nous avons demandé c'est mais
nous venons d'adresser une lettre au
premier ministre c'est que ce soit
peut-être modifier un peu la procédure
d'instruction la procédure d' enquête
d'utilité publique pour moi ce qui
précède le l'implantation d'une centrale
nucléaire
alors tout d'abord que les gens soient
prévenus très tôt dès qu'il ya les
premières études sur le terrain et puis
qu'ensuite tous les renseignements
soient plus accessibles notamment que
les mairies pas résoudre sont ouvertes à
des heures qui permettent à tout le
monde de venir alors qu'actuellement les
gens qui travaillent souvent éprouvé des
difficultés que les documents là aussi
soit des documents simple clair que les
gens puissent comprendre et ensuite
qu'il y ait peut-être plus
d'informations autres autour des
auditions alors pas du tout nous n'avons
pas demandé des auditions publiques car
il n'y a pas eu de majorité au sein du
conseil pour dire qu'il est vraiment des
crises mais qui viendront plus grande
information est le premier ministre
vient d'être saisie mais il ya une
dizaine de jours seulement
donc on ne peut pas naturellement entend
avoir pris les mesures en conséquence
par ailleurs en ce concerne la formation
encore le conseil lui-même s'est
beaucoup informer sur leurs constamment
vous allez tu l'entends des experts
alors nous avons tendu par cauet ce
faire ça il n'en avons pas aborder ces
problèmes et nous avons abordé par donc
les problèmes des conséquences médicales
éventuelle des problèmes de mesure des
radiations
lecointe dehors de refroidissement des
centrales à l'art est un dossier très
technique
catane est d'ailleurs donné lieu ensuite
il y a eu sur le voeu du conseil le
ministère de l'industrie organisé un
colloque sur cette question et mais
surtout tous nos rapports vont être
publiés il fallait attendre bien sûr
qu'ils constituent une certaine masse il
va y avoir un rapport d'activité annuel
pour 1978 nous occupons actuellement de
la présentation de l'impression et
surtout de ce que tous les gens pour
participer au débat demande
naturellement est ce que leur
intervention figure qu'à la suite et des
exposés qui ont été faits c'est une
certaines questions qui ont été posées
nous mettons tout cela en forme et nous
espérons que ce rapport est dupliquée
trilogie la meilleure demain conseil
interministériel consacré à les
pro-nucléaires précisément sera réunie
par raymond barre à l'hôtel matignon il
doit faire le point sur le déroulement
du programme nucléaire français
puis demain aussi je vous le rappelle
les services d'information d'antenne 2
vous proposeront leurs dossiers
troisième titre le voyage de menahem
begin au caire voyage historique même
s'il ne s'est pas passé comme tel dans
le monde arabe comme il est perçu comme
tel en tout cas et même en egypte on a
en effet un petit peu été surpris par la
toute petite place que lui accordait la
presse au caire et disons par le manque
d'enthousiasmé de part et d'autre sadi
l'accueil de la population a été bon
enfant et tout le monde reconnaissait
qu'il paraissait bien difficile il ya un
an
imaginez que viendrait le jour où un
orchestre militaire égyptien jour l in
israel
difficile aussi d'imaginer qu'un
président la république égyptien
offrirait un premier mini souffrait
offrir un premier tri sera lié à un
glaive de la paix arrivé en fin de
matinée au caire où pour la première
fois une musique militaire égyptienne a
joué la hatikva l'hymne national
d'israël et avant d'aborder la partie
touristique de son voyage en egypte
menahem begin a tenu à venir s'incliner
devant la tombe du soldat inconnu
égyptien un monument en forme de
pyramide qui a été érigé après la guerre
d'octobre 73 sans doute monsieur
béguines voulait-il par ce geste
rappelait que la visite que le président
sadate avait effectué au yad vashem le
monument low cost juifs ou vente son
voyage à jérusalem
monsieur begin et de ceux qui
accompagnent ce sont ensuite rendus aux
pyramides de gizeh le premier ministre
israélien s'est émerveillé de ses
chefs-d'oeuvre d'un générique comme il
les a appelés
je lui ai donné l'occasion d'évoquer
l'amitié nouvelle entre l'egypte et
israël et le désir de coopération et
d'entraidé qui sont maintenant
réalisable
entre les deux peuples peu de monde dans
les rues en revanche beaumont menahem
begin est arrivée la grande synagogue du
caire il faut dire qu'il fait
aujourd'hui 45 degrés à l'ombre dans la
ville mais une cérémonie émouvante
avaient été organisées à l'intérieur du
temple au monsieur begin a pu rencontrer
la petite colonie israélite du caire
c'est ce soir en tout cas que commencera
à l'aspect vraiment politique du voyage
au cours du dîner que le président
sadate doit offrir à son hôte
on attend beaucoup des toasts qui seront
prononcés à cette occasion et ils
pourraient c'est vrai d'un seul coup
détendre une atmosphère que du côté
égyptien c'est le moins que l'on puisse
dire n'est pas un enthousiasme
d'autant moins que la rumeur persistante
depuis une semaine de la démission du
premier ministre égyptien mustapha
khalil qui abonnés à washington les
derniers rounds des négociations
et bien cette rumeur s'amplifie elle
s'amplifie du fait aujourd'hui que
monsieur mustapha khalil n'était pas
présent à l'aéroport pour accueillir son
homologue israël en ce qui concerne le
voyage et ses résultats on y verra
certainement plus clair demain
après l'entretien de deux heures que
menahem begin aura avec le président
sadate
avant de rejoindre jérusalem à
l'étranger toujours un nouveau formateur
chez les belges c'est à dire un homme
chargé de former le futur gouvernement
ville fried martens il avait j'aurais
d'ailleurs été il y a quelques semaines
mais sa mission avait alors échoué voilà
trois mois que nos voisins n'ont pas de
cabine est stable même chose pour nos
amis italiens cette fois ci c'est le
présent à public qui a décidé de
dissoudre le parlement après la chute du
gouvernement monsieur andreotti on
devrait donc bientôt connaître la date
des prochaines élections
et puis encore un veto britannique dans
les institutions européennes la grande
bretagne s'est opposé aujourd'hui à
luxembourg à toute augmentation du
budget communautaire
un hommage du président giscard
d'estaing aux casques bleus français au
liban vous savez que l'un d'entre eux
est mort la semaine dernière le noeud le
nom de ceux qui ont donné leur vie
restera dans les mémoires pour cette
mission de paix écrit le chef de l'état
dans la préface un livre du collège
salvan blessé vous savez l'année
dernière je n'arrive donc aux affaires
françaises avec en politique ce grand
rendez vous qui vous attend tout de
suite après le journal jacques chirac
dans cartes sur table jacques chirac
interrogé par jean-pierre elkabbach yana
duhamel à 20h30
le président du rpr ne sera sans doute
pas insensible à la date
nous sommes en effet le 2 avril jour
anniversaire de la mort du président
pompidou
c'était il ya cinq ans et jacques chirac
étaient très attachés au président
défunt
valéry giscard d'estaing assistera
demain à une messe à sa mémoire
jacques chirac aura également à coeur je
pense de répondre aux critiques que lui
a faite très montbard au lendemain les
assises du rpr raymond barre qui avait
condamné je cite l'enflure et l'outrance
des propos de monsieur chirac donc
cartes sur table à 20h30 après le rpr le
ps depuis hier soir on connaît
exactement le rapport des forces des uns
et des autres 41 % 42 1% des mandats
très exactement pour françois mitterrand
24 pour michel rocard 14,4 pour jean
pierre chevènement et le crs 13,6 pour
pierre mauroy 7,7 pour gaston defferre
3,2 pour christian pire est c'est à dire
un des dissidents du ps et puis 0,3 pour
le courant femmes
c'est donc un succès daniel grandclément
un succès incontestable pour françois
mitterrand oui alors on s'attendait déjà
à ce que ce soit un succès n'aurait
peut-être pas à ce point là parce que si
l'on fait l'addition de ces voies plus
de celle de gaston defferre du moins une
grande partie de ces locations de faire
plus les quelques mandats qui n'en
compte pas de voler au secours de
victoire on s'aperçoit qu'il touche
qu'il fonde en tout cas la majorité
absolue et ça change tout il va aller au
congrès de metz n'ont pas en eux menacé
mais presque en vainqueur et cela
pourrait être un bon succès se dire
qu'il a vraiment en 1 toutes les cartes
vraiment la totalité il a toutes les
solutions il peut négliger rocard mauroy
et même le crs et gouverner tout seul
enfin il sera peut-être un petit peu
minorité amel peut gouverner quand même
il peut reconstituer l'ancienne majorité
du parti donc avec pierre mauroy et plus
difficilement avec michel rocard
si cela accepte découvre des concessions
en fait que se mettre d'accord avec le
crs parce que depuis quelques mois
françois mitterrand plutôt kuchi ses
positions enfin et là tout le monde peut
s'embrasser se rejoignent il y aurait
synthèse générale c'est à dire que tout
le monde serait dans la direction c'est
la dernière solution elle n'est pas
impossible non plus mais dans tous ces
cas de figure dépendent d'un homme
surtout d'un homme en tout cas de
françois mitterrand l'homme qu'elle plus
souffert dans ses votes de préparation
au congrès c'est pierre mauroy puisque
même dans sa propre fédération le pas de
calais n'obtient pas la majorité absolue
c'est ça je crois que pierre mauroy
comme le crs a souffert d'une des très
grandes lois de la vème république
c'est à dire qu aux yeux des militants
dans leur courant il n'y avait pas de
présidentiables c'est à dire que ni le
roi ni chevènement n'apparaissait comme
des présidentiables possible cela a dû
jouer je crois
même inconsciemment de la part des
militants voilà donc rpr ps et puisque
nous sommes à une semaine de ce congrès
de mai je pense que nous aurons
l'occasion d'en reparler très
prochainement avec une étude de
comparatif des différents courants nous
commenceront demain par celui de michel
rocard avec une étude signée patricia
charles rpr donc disais-je ps est
maintenant edf pour la première fois en
effet simone veil tête de liste une tête
de liste de soutien à l'action
européenne du président de la république
si manuel donc s'explique sur sa
conception de l'ordre alors la première
des questions qu'on va vous poser si
bonne nouvelle elle a trait à une
actualité d'hier c'est une proposition
c'est manu déclarations du premier
ministre il est encore de la presse
d'europe 1 il a dit qu'il allait
soutenir votre liste alors pensais pas
que votre responsabilité est accrue et
qu'une liste soutenue par le premier
ministre et donc implicitement par leur
père le public se doit de faire plus de
25% des suffrages
je ne veux pas donner de pourcentage
mais il est certain que je sens la
responsabilité de conduire sa fille très
grande et que c'est tout à fait
différent de ce qu'on se lorsqu'on se
présente dans une élection où l'on est
seul candidat là la responsabilité qui
m'incombe dépasse évidemment de beaucoup
celle que l'on doit éprouver je me sens
maintenant c'est que je ne sais pas par
expérience lorsque l'on est candidat aux
législatives ou même aux sénatoriales
mais simplement pour un siège puisqu'on
parle des relations au sein de la
majorité on va vous dire que votre
conception de l'europe se rapproche
davantage de celle du ps que de celle du
rpr
vous savez je crois que si l'on regarde
l'écran les conceptions européenne si
l'on écarte celle des communistes
en réalité elles sont très proches car
il s'agit pour tous d'une europe
confédérale
personne ne parle plus d'une europe
fédérale et d'une europe dont on parle
actuellement sur jeu d'ailleurs pour
l'ensemble des français
en dehors du parti communiste d'une
europe dans lequel chaque nation
conserve son indépendance son dessin
spécificités et je crois que sur ce
point il faut être tout à fait net
les crânes un repère ne sont quand même
pas les vôtres apparemment alors
simplement à la france et ça c'est à
dire que
le rpr craint que des élections de
l'assemblée européenne au suffrage
universel en train obligatoirement une
augmentation de ses pouvoirs mais je
crois que les déclarations du président
de la république ont été extrêmement
nettes et précises
c'est les pouvoirs de l'assemblée élue
ainsi au suffrage universel seront
identiques au pouvoir actuel et il n'est
pas question d'augmenter ses pouvoirs on
voit quand même la majorité allait
vraiment normes bataille très dispersé
elle va disperser on peut d'ailleurs
s'en étonner puisque en réalité les
positions sur le fond sont très proches
alors on peut dire que c'était un peu si
vous voulez une espèce de querelle
d'intention qui est fait au président de
ne pas être suffisamment ferme mais
pourtant dans le passé je crois qu'il a
clairement démontré qu'il entendait
maintenir les positions françaises au
sein de leur est ce qu'on peut savoir
par g bülach steve ott liste ne sera
qu'une liste de l'udf ou si elle sera un
peu élargie par exemple aux catégories
socio-professionnelles là que l'on
jouera compétences des allusions à dire
car nous avons déjà parlé avec les
représentants de l'udf et d'ailleurs
c'est qu edf au sein de chacune des
formations et en tant qu edf a également
évoqué le problème
il y aura vraisemblablement des
catégories représentant les catégories
socioprofessionnelles est ce que
monsieur de bâtisses entre armes je
crois pour l'instant donné absolument
aucun nom aussi longtemps que la liste
ne sera pas entièrement établi en accord
avec les représentants élus udf je n'ai
pas question de parler de tel ou tel
personnage
c'est à dire dans combien de temps la
publication de cette liste je ne sais
pas je pense que d'ici 15 jours nous
serons fixés
je remercie ce mail j'ajoute pour
compléter ce chapitre politique que
c'était aujourd'hui séance de rentrée à
l'assemblée une science quelque peu
éclipsé par la session ordinaire du mois
dernier
daniel brême à noter pour nous la
proposition aujourd'hui de gaston
defferre une commission d' enquête sur
les problèmes de la sécurité dans les
centrales nucléaires françaises nous en
parlions à l'instant et puis
l'inquiétude de huit députés udf qui
demande à la majorité de se ressaisir et
d'oublier justement que de part et
d'autre c'est procès d'intention et ses
querelles reford de reçus ce matin par
valéry giscard d'estaing le p dg de la
deuxième pierre mme mondial automobile
qui venait de voir raymond barre s'est
montré extrêmement discret à sa sortie
l'elysée on ne sait donc pas si monsieur
faure 2
ou si même l'ensemble ford implantera ou
non une usine
en lorraine un secteur industriel qui
marchent l'aéronautique française vient
d'enregistrer de très beaux succès
d'abord la commande de réacteurs
conscient par type à la snecma est un
contrat de plusieurs centaines d'unités
pour équiper des décès huit américains
et puis surtout le gros contrat
lufthansa la compagnie allemande vient
en effet de commander ce matin 25 airbus
et à la prise option pour 25 contre
voilà une nouvelle qui a dû faire je
pense plaisir du côté de toulouse
celle en tout cas que jean claude renaud
et jean le berre ont mené leur enquête
c'était le 15 mars le pdg de la
compagnie swissair vient d'acheter ferme
cinq airbus 310 et de prendre options
sur cinq autres
le vendeur à droite c'est bernard
latière pdg du consortium airbus
industrie il est content ses avions se
vendent bien
l'airbus 300 d'abord est demandée par 21
une compagnie 132 commandes fermes
cinquante sept options 189 appareils au
total le petit dernier ensuite l'airbus
310 qui n'est pas encore construit mais
déjà vendu suisse air en acheter 5 60
sont prises en option
l'airbus est une réussite incontestable
un succès technique
la preuve les américains disent turner
line sont boudés boeing pour commander
30 2 rbds un succès commercial en était
fier de la caravelle vendu à 280
exemplaires
on espère vendre au moins 400 airbus de
la première version
enfin ce sera sans doute une réussite
financière
la vente de 360 appareils remboursera
les avances consenties pour la
fabrication de l'avion n'ayant pas le
meilleur avion volant actuellement au
monde et c'est le cas nous aurions un
mal énorme à passer au dessus de la
compétition américaine qui je le
rappelle il ya encore 2 en 2000 elle
marchait 99% et en moins de deux à trois
ans nous avons réussi à devenir le
deuxième constructeur de gros porteur au
monde puisque l an dernier nous avons
vendu autant de gros porteur que boeing
et autant que le kid et douglas réunis
eh ben il n'y a pas de recette ne se
vend pas comme une savonnette au coin de
la rue
chaque contrat est un contrat qui porte
sur des centaines de milliards d'anciens
francs
donc en fait ça diffère d'une compagnie
est une autre et en adoptant compagnie
mais en réalité au lan audition devant
un costume sur mesure haut le drapeau
site de confection alors quelles sont
vos ambitions pour la famille en bus
combien vous voulez vendre d'appareils
de transition assez facile à donner
c'est à peu près de prendre le quart ou
le tiers du marché
donc faites vos calculs on devrait
normalement arriver à quelque chose
entre 700 et 1000 avions airbus
industrie c'est l'europe iron outils
cinq pays réunis dans un consortium la
france l'allemagne fédérale
la grande-bretagne l'espagne membre à
part entière avec la hollande associés
chacun de ces pays fabrique une partie
de l'avion dans ses propres usines
selon un pourcentage établi par exemple
la voilure en bleu foncé et construite
par les anglais la cellule avant en
jaune par les allemands et les
hollandais
une fois monté toutes les pièces
convergent vers toulouse ou
l'aérospatiale réalise l'assemblage de
l'avion
à l'heure actuelle les revues s'est
fabriqué au rythme de deux avions et
demi par mois mais il faut accélérer la
cadence pour satisfaire les clients
on passera à trois airbus dès le mois
d'octobre puis 680 pour atteindre 8 à 10
appareils par mois
en 83 ce défi c'est toute l'industrie
aéronautique française l'aérospatiale en
tête qui doit le relever
l'enjeu est de taille airbus c'est un
marché de 33 milliards de francs c'est
l'emploi garanti dans l'aéronautique
pendant 15 ans dix mille français
travaillent actuellement pour airbus
on estime qu'ils seront vingt mille le
double en 1984 mais attention cela ne
veut pas dire que 10000 emplois vont
être créés
car certains salariés au lieu de
fabriquer des avions en perte de vitesse
travailleront désormais pour le
programme serbie mais il faudra tout de
même embauché les casseurs à nouveau à
la une du 10 hier aujourd'hui et pour
deux jours encore une vingtaine de
personnes arrêtées après l'incident du
23 mars seront jugés devant la chambre
des flagrants délits à paris compte
rendu d'audience par paul lefèvre dans
notre belle et journal les obsèques de
bruno coquatrix
décédé hier d'une crise cardiaque se
dérouleront mercredi à paris au père
lachaise
bruno coquatrix auteur compositeur
inventeur de vedettes découvreur de
talents son nom restera je croise aussi
à celui du music-hall qu'il dirige l
olympia où le spectacle continue ce soir
la première de colette renard
c'est une autre génération qui pleurera
la disparition de jean lumière qui vient
de mourir ce matin à paris à l'âge de 84
ans il fêtait il y a une cinquantaine
d'années l'un des chanteurs les plus
populaires et à la fin de ce journal
nous vous ferons un goûter l'un de ses
succès une histoire vraie que nous vous
racontant parce que l'été mouvante près
mais un étudiant de san salvador est
mort sous la torture mort de trop
ressembler son frère c'était l'un des
leaders étudiants l'université
cela s'est passé il ya quelques semaines
en amérique du sud et bien ce matin rémy
qui était étudiant en économie politique
à vincennes devait soutenir un mémoire
de maîtrise une thèse qui sera néanmoins
ceux défendus par l'ensemble de ses
professeurs dont le prix nobel
alfred kastler et ceci devant l'ombre
aux étudiants en hommage une page sports
pour vous donner la composition de
l'équipe de france qui affrontera la
tchécoslovaquie après demain à
bratislava et qui sera un match qui sera
retransmis vous savez sur antenne 2 vers
18 heures pas de grosse surprise dans
cette équipe
à noter toutefois d'abord que lopez sera
capitaine emplacements de marius trésor
de monégasques petit a été préféré à
michel en milieu de terrain
et puis seul à cette étude elle concerne
le poste d'arrière gauche
bossis à la faveur de michel hidalgo
mais il ne sait pas s'il ne s'est pas
remis de sa blessure au doigt
c'est tu sautes de nantes qui le
remplacera mini pollution en bretagne
une plage de douarnenez soulier ce matin
sur environ 2 km un accostage un petit
peu sec avec un remorqueur et une brèche
à travers laquelle s'échappe 20 à 30
tonnes de mazout des soutes du pétrolier
liberia le psy valiante l'incident s'est
produit après l'opération de
transbordement qui avait allégé hier le
temps guère de séquelles que 72 mille
tonnes de pétrole sur place le nettoyage
est assurée par une cinquantaine de
pompiers par des employés du service de
l'équipement
la page de la météo pour ces dernières
journées d'avril et bien les qu'elle
ressemble à s'y méprendre aux derniers
jours de mars
c'est assez dire qu'aujourd'hui encore
on a retrouvé un temps mi figue mi
raisin avec alternance de passages
nuageux d'averses et de quelques
éclaircies dans le midi pour demain vous
le voyez cela va continuer il est vrai
que laurent broomhead nous avait avertis
demain donc
après une matinée fraîche le ciel sera
variable
après des averses orageuses par endroits
qui donneront de la neige au dessus de
500 mètres
le temps d'une page publicité et vous
aurez je vous le rappelle un nouveau
rendez vous ce soir avec la rédaction
d'antenne 2 cartes sur table une
émission de jean pierre elkabbach et
allah dieu mail avec comme invité
jacques chirac
et puis en fin de journal alors fin de
soirée par dans le dernier journal qui
vous sera présenté aux environs de 23h
15 par hervé claude il est temps de
prendre congés et comme promis nous
allons le faire en compagnie de jean
lumière qui nous à perdre est l'un de
ses plus grands succès
bonsoir à demain
ce soir dès que la fois du rein venu
quand les étoiles le sujet
et métros des clous dans son dos de la
nuit
nous partirons seuls tous les deux dans
la nuit brune en amoureux sont en cours
mais à